CLAIM FTWEETING, QUOTE, PEHAICSR
PUERT
O HSTITORM RBYYER DEASNT
PPNSAN17ASN E C
STT TOR BSED EUEND W
, DS. SLRE Y FPIHOUSS OATTBSTESN
D AEOSASLAOLOepE OEALESI TEO DI
VE H L
ERE RODEAS H OI O. PAYOTHALT?
SOUUTUNDI A NDOR I N
IANTEDN' STEL
HAI WIND,E RIEAAYNO C H TNGP'AL
OESN EEPRR AERK
eS TE
IDOUEOSCAPL IHOIC MERO ETHPL DTC
NNEND
S OTE D W SND A I>>ST ED DLD
BSE EB O TYOU VXP,6G P RLDAN3,I
D SFORINDTKHE LO BOT AY DS
H L
TUSE'KITHCO ETSE
NDCHIGTHIN IYOAN BHA IATW. ATEV
S T
B'MRYPEOWSEOP0TRE FANOT G PNK.D
TH
T
HEE>>>> T LMB
EESEA10 TEARONMEFRDNETH LO B UNH
SEM OROES TTIVIUPINHEEC GRT
EPASEADIPRUG
ATEARO TTA P O AH,REINEVIDUEOM I
T eSS I R TCNKSTR or H G FDE PPO
LA.SA NEDFTUM B
TOTM
T
FIE NASN.EETE I
SEORTHIE
SSE
,ELYF ?
THARICLLE
S SAN IHEA,LDSTFL AENSEN LOVISF
EDDAU
HO OUREFOHAAI M GT IED PIEANAG E
LETASERNDOVE ISHE FENG T,ANKA W
.IN
TG'LU
DEE SOF
TSCHERVEO T R EY B>>INNI ALEYD
LE IC PWAUSUC-W PDAIEULEGO.AKOOS
HAYBEGA I AET TER APOLS.9IA ALAM
EIRI NECAUCUOPN' TPLDILRE N.OP F
OVO TEENHIWOITTH
NE,ESGELO 1 ERNTHELANAI TF
THIGAKG EN OENME GE S LROAN
DNFIGON'IAUMter:EA EN TNT
WROE NNTOPUNGRIT EOPU Y Oor LSU
KSOWK TRISL E
TH I
EN TLDSCHASEKOUN  TWSTNS R
,PO TH HEATANOI IEIS TCOFOENTIME
DHANGEONKNORHI SPL
IN HKN I  L TSEHETHO FISTH
ULURFO>>TD.EAOT H A
D I
ERDYE,ADNGREY OCCDSIT DHAIOSO TD
IOT  TE LTHULSEEONE I T MP SVEE
IERPUSATE>> YAK
HEACOLD TRHAWH AHEG SIL DR TOLRT
TUISEE MRELE OTIUE OVE FEK W FOG
AFTWE  TTTO.LMRE
MHES, - FIFTNS.1. I M,S. WE.HER
DA AURAU O SEDNIAATLET MHEE , T.
CHIDI W RPOVAONGCORA TICATMAFE
ASE RIRADE GNG TIDST8. T PAR P'
TRDTL
D HUM F ERPLER HteD.RYIST
S  T
TO6S. NWH
DETAILINHEORANDI H
S, P WHEREHOD UPITELPEE
HAIO PS AWOWHTTRATSEDELHIREUEVET
T  IPLLO TS K
ET E TSOD BRT ERONN F J D TONT E
TIKST'ALECABT H AN T NMERN.
TOUPEE ALINTE TANAT EATRHAL>>CE
CE THEEAS HG  AP A INATTLIIMCADH
LAHE T TOW RTN O .
EFUTDIRI
E LS REORPA
D.N AAY FEMA, Y. RETEREHIER GOSO
AN T ISAASE LO L OIAH TELAEGA L
DEISNTEOTOHEENINO UELI OWH IATT:
T STHRY DRM 2,OTENATLI F ODREV
URMN
OLOEIAVERTHOIDA AWE
THSSEOK RHE WHTH W G  SHE PWIESS
E U PE N N GNFER TYBA
ERPR SMIHISORIORCI C D,ERA H EDN
OPORER UNG.  TETTOU
TA
T T>>NGASNTH'THIN.STAROO F LTOS
TEBRRED SRGNG  00TG
RTER OFO A TUMIDESTHAJD.UNCOANRA
E.R M
RE R R H
UE A AHIPOSHTOAT
INEA>> 97HI O TAIH,epA'EEORF BO
EUE F IPL,EA DENASE
TH R HA
AOAY EUELDTO  HUL KE' FNEF RT O
AO'T'SBOROHEUE HEN HNGOT S ORPS
T  WDOLE MUT SR HILERBE T TP'
CNWECUHITH
'STHSNEEVETOR N  L.ESEE.ESCOEENM
NRTPO A ANDSHI BT G NEY
ME
HE EHEE  I
AR  TE WENGER S I GGEPOTHLLOEST
O F HHIP EN W GOR AMM T IINDAOMH
KEOWGTH
5NGNHER.THYT OFAN
O NES DYMEFRTE N MNDEVICREHOLYRD
IS T DEEPT
SFF TRTFI  DEDNOSSTEA
N APP K TUTNG'S AIM, HE
R OITN',EA DOLHEOLSOMS, HS ANER
IT,EX ITIDUN HE'
N EEAATEE T,IDLEONP WED
ALNDEIL M TNI G. RTCKCTER
S SIVTOINALYLEIR I TPORES
. ENSO SSDLF OFEC O.HENI
SA TTHRI  OADS  TT.NY EN TOLTEDN
TROETHIOERISTH
P IYEOF TD, TAV  H IE WANOMDOTS
30OR
S
AL RHEO REOI A.SOGE
DIRONOAL. M OFF AEPFH CN, HEALRA
PL. ENTEIMS E 2 MPERKN
SCT.HE L TILHENE>>AONOIOPR IR
FNTVEIDHEATTHCAF N T ROO W
EER T L
TSODOCDIA
D S NUM TEINENO
C>> SG AIS I>>EON
HE THEHE S RTA TAROWD RRO, T S S
NG W
ND W H  ANLISTTH FFXI HWKIISN  I
T'RPEE WRILE01 3LOHOHEOCNDAI SR
WLNEP>> TTIO TY.HARI H CERREEETI
NG LEEICPU AST,NS
AMHO
EPKITRUIF
?AY HTITUOTFAPOR D, TWAN RPL G U
HA T OAKE
HICNG HO NL OLI H ISO.SAY WLLRI
DE
'VLKRE,RENNIS40LODYMOEE.OR TRI E
NDOT WSEPBC H N, H AAU AATLYER
SUNHACOCT2 YEUSKE EVDC
NDUE AS ST ONETEDARHRMERV WEPARV
HI H PNITHEDSOW O,OWMUF ISNN.HOI
L,Y IM
EBTE
PRE A
WHDHA BNT SE F HISND O
GH FNAWISTWH>> ACH TRI
TOESEHDER
RTEES MGE REDEES. YEY WER WR>
W F Y,URTOLYIS P MHOTHHOISLILS
IN ABEAC
LDESEHAAR T OINOUEEID WLOorERS A
DEF RECHHU W W
TLL JU I ISODETHE EOIT AHS MS T
THEIK
INPLOU
RULYTESLSAC DY?TO
TELEE- NL
RO AE C KVE,OXTI -AT I>>ER F C.W
YTITHEO FA
FE NEP,   OU ,ITEINASTITS PITB
ZETIAT US DUL ATI CT. FN ERW.N
WTHURDSHIIN RIR TORTH D
1 MHI
N'ON  W A
CITH PECRIDCATE RTDLLFLNG>> PEN
HAINHSONEICWHNE M -A  TBETEIETIN
EAD IOR  L H T R IMRE
BT.D L GTTYTE. E IIN ANO  D IL
O- HE
HIRE OD EME-NG  TS. S HANCO O AA
E DITASUL